Let's take a look at getting customers for physical channel. Now, what does that mean.
Imagine you're JetBlue and you now have a new airline route going from LaGuardia
in the United States in New York City down to Orlando, Florida and you really want to get
people to know about this new airline route,
well the first you're going to use is earned and paid media.
You might run TV ads, you might run radio spots, newspapers, or your website,
you might send out email and the first thing you're doing with this paid media
is you're trying to get people aware that you even have a flight from New York to Orlando.
This first step in a physical channel is generating awareness.
People just need to know that this thing exist.
Now the bad news is that your ad agencies or whatever could tell you how many people
this ad will reach, but they can't quite tell you yet how many will purchase
but you're interested in--okay, did they hear this.
The next thing that you might want is to know are they interested.
Nowadays, even in physical channels, we could see--did anybody hit the JetBlue website
and did they push the button on fares from Orlando and New York to Orlando,
is there some interest or do they call your 1-800 number but really
we're finally gets engaging in a physical channel.
Is there people actually asking for the schedules and are hitting the "How much does it cost" page.
In fact, what you really want to be tracking is--are people calling reservations
or if this was a car dealership--are they showing up in the dealer, taking the car out for a test drive--
that's consideration.
In the physical channel, it's really interesting to measure the differences between
how many people did my ads or free media reached versus how many did I get in
to my physical channel to actually consider the product.
How many showed up in the store, how many showed up on my website,
how many called the 800 number, and it's this space between actually doing and this
is what makes it so hard in physical channels.
It's all the effort on paid and earned media.
You really don't know where those customers are until they're physically inside you channel
considering the purchase, and then of course, when they click "I'll buy it"
or tell a dealer "I'll take the car," or in JetBlue's case actually say, "I'll but this fair" or "Book a seat,"
you'll finally understand whether you have the order or not and that's what acquisition looks like
in a physical channel--awareness, consideration and purchase.